welcome back to me rockstars I'm Erik
Bosse and the New Mutants movie is
happening the young adult horror or take
on the x-men comics from director Josh
Boone was originally gonna come out two
years ago with its first teaser trailer
the subject of new actors first-ever
panel show in October 2017 remember that
back when the outer shirt still fit
after several delays and reshoot says
these x-men properties that Fox were
acquired by Disney and Marvel Studios
Marvel ultimately decided that a cut of
the film that was closest to Boone's
original vision Stephen King inspired
psychological horror without tie-ins to
the older x-men films would be okay to
release you know we really saw they
don't lose all of that money they
already spent on it does this make the
New Mutants part of the MCU officially
but we're not sure the movie was not
produced by Marvel Studios but there are
ways that Kevin Feige and his team could
retroactively leaf it this film into his
market they swore plan I'll get to those
as I break down this new mutant trailer
shot-by-shot for all the details and
easter eggs that you might have missed
and spoiler warning in case any of my
predictions are too right and they ruin
your life let's get started the opening
clip introduces us to Danielle Moonstar
aka the mutant Mirage in the Marvel
Comics played here by blue hunt Mirage
is the Native American mutant with the
ability to create illusions based on
one's fears and desires in this case the
pure desire is for snowflakes to turn
into good one of Danny's other
manifestations in the comics is that of
the demon bear an entity that feeds on
negative emotions and killed Annie's
parents aunt will be an antagonist in
this film the demon bear begins as
something Danny thinks is her own
projection but actually has an external
origin notice how in this trailer
footage Danny can be seen wearing a bear
necklace maybe signaling the demon bears
possession over her but also the demon
bear could be possessing other
characters in this movie but before he
continued think you do raid for
sponsoring this episode
raid is an epic dark fantasy game done
right a hero collection turn-based game
with over 400 champions for you to
collect personally customized in the
best part it's free to play let's check
out these different champions that you
can collect and battle with you got a
mister Minotaur with very practical
saw swords because I have one when you
connect to one appears to have a stag
and look he's got steam coming out from
his undercarriage if you could see I
often pick my champions purely based on
how tough they look to compliment my
complete lack of tough-looking this you
can also go to the portal to open shards
you have earned it look at these shards
I've earned them and you could battle
against other players in the arena or go
on an epic campaign to increase the
experience of your new characters enjoy
a bully boys story right now gamers can
claim free champions and more with
Amazon Prime just log in to raid Shadow
legends and sign up before January 12 to
claim two million silver and 700 energy
future drops run through April and
include the champions spur in Vala along
with free shards XP boosts legendary
artifacts potions and everything else
you need to take on rival summoners
claim your loot today Bram's on Prime
members only
just install raid from my links below
and follow the instructions inside the
game and now you can play raid both on
mobile and on your desktop the game is
cross device so you can play with these
same user and switch between devices
whenever you want and however you want
it the graphics are amazing in the PC
version of the game and the game is
super fast so what are you waiting for
go down to the video description click
on these special links and you will get
50,000 silver with a free epic champion
as part of the new player program to
start your journey good luck and I'll
see you there but let's get back to the
trailer creepy faces pushing through the
walls at Danny now this is a nod to Wes
Craven's famous shot in the Nightmare on
Elm Street spoon even use the same
practical approach of a sheet of spandex
to push people spaces through this
movie's plot was partly inspired by the
third Nightmare on Elm Street movie
dream warriors in which Freddy Krueger's
young victims including Porsha sure
can't are trapped in a mental hospital
Craven's famous stretch wall represented
Freddy's attempt to push through that
dream barrier into the kids reality the
same way the demon bear is pushing
through the barrier between these
mutants nightmares and their awoken
lives woke lives that I don't know their
politics let's move on
the reason you survived it's because
you're a very uncommon girl okay here we
see the flashback of the moments Danny
loses her father as they plead from
blinging wreckage that crashes behind
them perhaps this is the attack by the
demon bear and she wakes up handcuffed
in a bed in this mental hospital
observed by dr. Cecilia Reyes played by
Alice Braga Cecilia Reyes is an x-men
character a good guy you can project uh
psychic shield around herself but he or
she seems to be a darkly motivated
hospital administrator similar to Nurse
Ratched from One Flew Over the Cuckoo's
Nest this whole Hospital as a shield
barrier that traps the patients inside
maybe that barrier is generated by Reyes
it's interesting how Danny here says he
said we had to run she could be
referring to her father or she could be
describing the voice of the demon bear
an entity who wants her to run from it
because it beast saw her fear moving on
do you know a mutants or would anyone
like to shared their first time brain I
was 13 I thought it was a dream but just
lost control
okay here we see the hospital itself
with the faded name Melbury hospital
Melbury could be a nod to nathan
Millbury an alternate name of Nathaniel
Essex aka mr. sinister from the x-men
comics he was the genetic engineering
antagonist mutant did seem like he was
being set up as a big bad of the x-men
films before this will shake up happened
originally mr. sinister was going to be
revealed in this movies post-credit
scene played by Jon Hamm as a connection
to that Essex shout out in the
post-credits scene for x-men apocalypse
now that cameo was scrapped during
reshoots and the character was
supposedly replaced by Antonio Banderas
as a different unconfirmed role but
still this hospital retains the Millbury
name skeleton of the broader Fox x-men
universe that this movie was originally
going to expand into real life this
location is the Medfield State Hospital
in Massachusetts the same location whose
for the asylum in Shutter Island which
is another psychological horror film
with patients trapped in a surreal
nightmare Reyes introduces us to the
other mutants starting with Raymond
Sinclair aka Wolfsbane played by Maisie
Williams from Game of Thrones she has
the power to shape-shift into a wolf
girl's got a type Ray and has an M on
her neck perhaps is a kind of self
branding for mutant and I'm guessing up
a new direction for all future x-men
films will be for mutant to be the go-to
term instead of x-men now rain as a
character is very religious she has
difficulty reconciling her werewolf
supernatural abilities with her
spirituality Josh Boone noted that he
was raised by very religious parents
evangelical Southern Baptists who took
literal things like the rapture the
devil demons leading to his affinity for
the demon bear and reigns in her
conflicts may serve as a kind of
analogue for the director himself moving
on Sam Ash why are you panicking
people got hurt
Liberto my girlfriend okay next we meet
the mutant Sam Guthrie aka cannonball
played by Charlie Heaton from extremes
of things he has the power to project
himself through the air with
invulnerability we get a sense of that
power with a shot of his skin glowing
spasming notice how his arm is broken
perhaps due to him testing his powers
but continuing to smash through
something after he was powered down next
there's Roberto Jocasta a gay sunspots
played here by Henry Sega who has the
ability to keep his collar pops long
after everyone realized how douchey it
is Bobby decosta is a Brazilian mutant
with the ability to manipulate solar
energy similar to the Human Torch but
not the same thing the previous version
of sunspot actually showed up in x-men
Days of Future past and some thought
that they saw the name Roberto decosta
on the memorial wall and Avengers in the
game but as someone who went through
that damn scene very much for any man
dozen times at all I started seeing
demon bears everywhere I never found it
Bobby hints at a pretty horrific
backstory that involves him accidentally
burning his girlfriend maybe by firing
up during sex in a pool or maybe like
causing the pool water to super boil
with her in it let that be a warning
kids having unprotected sex in a pool is
just as dangerous as having sex with a
fiery mutant on to the next clip
Julianne I killed 18 one
[Music]
this isn't a hospital it's a cage okay
the final new mutant we meet is Illyana
Rasputin make a magic played by anya
taylor joy she is the sister of colossus
and she's a number of abilities
including the power of teleportation and
sorcery through the limbo dimension and
manifestation eldritch armor across her
body and the use of a psychic blade
called the soul sword which gets
stronger with each use and she brags
here about killing 18 men with shots of
men's bodies collecting snow how could
you be me but this reminds me of the
infamous of Dyatlov past mystery in
which nine russian hikers died in the
northern Ural Mountains in 1959 due to
unexplained circumstances and I'm not
playing this movie's gonna say magic
murdered the DI love pass hikers just
that one of the many mysterious deaths
in Russian folklore could be tied to
this mutant we hear the music of this
trailer Pink Floyd's another brick in
the wall famously used as a protest by
rebellious youth against a strict
authoritarian schooling the lyric we
don't need no thought control is
especially relevant here with the way
the demon bear is attempted to hijack
all of their perceptions of reality as
Aliana confesses this you can see that
she's clearly in a different room in the
shot with sensors on her fingers perhaps
under police interrogation Danny
discovers the barrier on the hospital
grounds keeping them trapped as if in a
cage the barrier design is similar to
the look of the invisible barrier in the
movie cabin in the woods in which five
young people were similarly locked in a
horror experiment now if we assume that
the demon bear is the big bad to all of
us perhaps he is possessing Reyes and
using her shield projection abilities to
trap all of these mutants in a fake
hospital setting because notice so we
don't really see anyone else working at
this hospital
other than Reyes the demon bear could be
attempting to trick these kids into
thinking they're getting better this is
all an illusion created by the demon
bear to keep these mutants in a
perpetual state of fear as a kind of
farm that this bear can continually
feast on this is why farmers hate bears
moving on
it's important we find out at your
collar so we can help you get better
I suppose something
I don't think she wanted me to see here
Reyes plays Big Brother watching the
security screens but then she straps
down Danny on a gurney with a gas mask
over her face perhaps and do see her
with hallucinogens to trigger her fears
then there's a very creepy shot of these
bald tattooed figures wearing masks
smothering someone notice how their
fingers are all unnaturally long now the
teaser from two years ago these masks
are basic happy faces but if you freeze
a shot as he removed it to Kazee what
looks like a really freaky distorted
face under there perhaps we could be
seeing a manifestation of magic sphere
like men with Russian style Prison
tattoos on their bodies who stalk and
smother me and meet her her no moving on
[Music]
I think we're here to get better here
Eliana salmon rain explore the haunted
house environment of this hospital where
one of the doors peels away into
nothingness is evil laughter chuckles
out of them and then one of the bald
figures drops behind them again nope
we're moving on this place
he's there okay here we see Danny
running alone in the snowy woods perhaps
this is part of the scene where the
demon bear took her father and then Sam
nervously creeps through a coal mine
maybe the demon bear is forcing him to
relive a traumatic moment like maybe he
was in a coal mine when he first muses
Canabalt powers and caused it to
collapse and crush all these other
miners Rana grieves in a cemetery with
numbered graves perhaps the numbers
refer to past young mutants who died
after being completely consumed by the
demon bear and then we see rain and her
churches confessional booth the top of
which gets bitten off by the demon bear
and you can see its teeth and glowing
red eyes Derek's on to the next clip we
can get out of this together
this section there's a clip of sunspot
in his fiery glory it looks as Z's in
that church location we saw rain so
maybe he's rescuing her from the demon
bear punching through the pews that are
thrown at him and the coolest looking
shot of this trailer for me is the
effects on Ellie on his arm as armor
assembles into her clutching the
soul-sword as much as I loved Colossus
in the Deadpool movies we never got to
see him transformed from his human form
into his metallic form he's always just
as metal form so I don't think this
magic is meant to be the exact sister of
that same Colossus from the Deadpool
movies but rather both Deadpool in the
New Mutants and habits separate Marvel
sub universes and perhaps this idea of
sub universes will explain how Marvel
Studios intends to connect new mutants
to the MCU because we just learned that
Marvel Studios decided to move a 1
divisions release on Disney Plus earlier
to this year we also know that Wan
division will explore the character of
Wanda Maximoff a mutant by the way and
her sorcery powers as a witch and that
all this will directly set up the events
of Doctor Strange in the multiverse of
madness a horror inspired story so what
if the new mutants ends with a
post-credits scene in which we learn
that these young mutants exist in a
separate reality perceived by MCU want a
maximov a hypothetical nightmare has she
been jiz away through the multiverse of
Lana's this way the interview could
retroactively lis justify all of the Fox
x-men events is just alternate histories
within the marvel cinematic multiverse
of which earth one 99999 the one of the
MCU is just one of the infinite
universes honestly they could kind of
suck in every movie universe in this way
wrap your head around this possibility
as we move on to the final clip
here Ilyana drops from a portal and this
all appears to be outside that church a
huge hole is ripped in its facade
suggesting this is all part of that same
Church battle with the demon bear we hit
our clearest ever look at that demon
bear if said demon bear like 50 times in
this video as it Wars and then one final
shot of the battle with Ileana chasing
this entity which is now abstracted
smokey the demon bear does appear as a
smokey cloud in the comics maybe this is
an adaptation of that and then on the
other side of the entity is Sam you can
see the cast but also interestingly some
other figure flapping wings is it blasts
the entity with a blue energy beam is
this another mutant is it like a
positive manifestation by mirages to
help fight the demon bear let me know
what you think this is in the comments
below and how do you think Marvel
Studios might try to connect the new
mutants to the MCU follow me on
instagram and twitter at EA vas and
subscribe to new rock stars for
breakdowns of everything you love thanks
for joining me
[Music]